President Eisgruber, I have the honor to
present to you for the degree of Humane
Letters honoris causa
Lonnie G bunched the 3rd in the study of
history found his muse and his mission
to give voice to the voiceless and to
make visible the invisible as founding
director of the National Museum of
african-american history and culture he
raised the necessary funds collected
nearly 40,000 objects and secured a site
on the National Mall
a place where slaves once toiled and
where King once dreamed with vision
perseverance diplomacy and what
President Barack Obama called his street
smarts he created a magnificent space
which tells the American story through
the African American lens we are proud
to honor this curator of a people's
journey just a kid from Jersey as he
calls himself who has shown us how to
use history to make America better
al-tohra Tata Mejia Cora Torre basura
Satara spring catonian Cisco Missa
Tay odd Branham doctores Inlet heiress
lumen eorum us honora's causa admitto